Jim and Jennifer are with us and your
daughters names again this is Claire
uh-huh and this is Madeline and our
third one who is at Ohio University big
shout out to her is Amelia Dave we have
paid off little over one hundred and
fifty four thousand dollars my gosh yes
before financial piece I would say our
lives were just I don't want to say
flying by the seat of our pants
but flying by the seat of our pants okay
flying by the seat of our pants just out
of control with spending but the funny
thing is didn't know we were out of
control so what kind of debt as a
hundred and fifty four thousand what did
you people buy we asked ourselves the
same question I need that I want that
did it went out and got it didn't think
twice about it a couple of cars
timeshare yep and yeah and some business
debt the pressure of having all that
debt I probably would let off a little
bit of tension but he also kept a lot of
stuff in I think and because he knew
that if I knew it would be even more
stressful I was protecting you honey
I was protecting
so what happened three years and ten
months ago that you guys looked up and
said okay we're in debt then you know
what happened well I go ahead we were at
church and they were just advertising
Financial Peace University
simultaneously we looked at each other
and we should do this we should do this
is something we need and we need it now
it's just laid out so simply number one
you put a thousand dollars in the bank
number two this is how you're gonna
attack your debt just do it just do it
stop talking about it and just do it a
couple of things that we sold were some
jewelry so there's the old case so I
just put my old ring back in it I never
know what time it is so I always pull my
phone out cuz I had a watch it was so
close to getting rid of her but we kept
her yeah it was just an awakening it's
like hey look at all of this stuff that
you're doing that is just you know so
wrong you know well stuff that you could
have done smarter for example the
couponing she saved us half well I'm
through couponing on a monthly basis
it's great it's almost a challenge to me
how low can I get my grocery bill to
even ninety nine dollars and 38 cents I
stayed below 100 I'm like okay the
grocery store sometimes and and they've
owed me money and we had we had one
issue throughout though we had our
countertop oh it it cracked it it's
split so we had guys come in to give us
a price and are like it can't be
repaired it's done you have to replace
it at a cost of like $10,000 Oh - so
this became affectionately known as
Dave's crack
we would look at it and and we would say
what would Dave do the hair it is that's
Dave's crack $200 later I fixed it it's
you can see a little bit in there oh
really doesn't that to be replaced at
all no no not anymore
every day when we cook spelled out its
snowball effect brake rolls and rolls
and rolls and then each accomplishment
each debt that gets there just get you
to that next one you get that gazelle
intensity yes we can really do this yeah
and then it just was on autopilot all
right gentleman Jennifer count it down
let's hear a great a player can sit down
free screen
absolutely fabulous you know it Dave
always says it changes your family tree
you bet it does
yeah well we get money by doing I get
money from doing my job no part of it in
chores this is my chore thing we're good
save and spend money then these are the
money right the money the money amount
that I get let me tell you about a
really easy financial plan that can just
transform your life I mean in every
aspect of your life you know to pick one
snippet out of our lives that was you
know the best enhancement because
they're going through this know it's
everything money does have something to
do with every aspect of your life to a
much bigger degree when you're in debt
and then once you're not in debt anymore
everything's just better